I think most importantly enjoy your life
and there's a fine line between today
and tomorrow
and I think the trick is to enjoy today
and prepare for tomorrow if you do too
much of either then you lose the real
value of life Kenny Rogers was a man who
made every day count the country legend
died of natural causes on Friday at the
age of 81 and now the music industry is
rallying together to show their love and
support
I loved Kenny with all my heart my
heart's broken and a big old chunk of it
has gone with him today
Dolly Parton was a longtime collaborator
and friend of Kenny's people really says
what we really feel we are so I think
soul partners I believe we are there's
different kinds of soul mates but it's
like with Kitty I just see him and I
smile she is my best friend yay I feel
the same way the duo was famous for
duets like this
[Music]
and this
[Music]
not think that I can speak for all his
family his friends and fans when I say
that I will always love you Lionel
Richie was also close with the country
icon he wrote one of Kenny's biggest
hits lady
[Music]
get
[Applause]
lyonell shared a series of photos on
instagram with a heartfelt message in
the caption reba mcentire also posted a
touching tribute
so did fellow country stars Keith Urban
Blake Shelton and LeAnn Rimes
[Music]
et's last interview with Kenny was in
2017 when he received a star on the
Music City Walk of Fame music comes and
goes the Hall of Fame is forever and a
walk a star that's pretty forever but
Kenny wasn't just proud of his music
career he was also proud of his personal
life he shared the secret to being
married for over two decades to his wife
Wanda
one is a very special girl she's much
younger than I am and she has a good
sense about her and her parents are very
religious and so she has a debtor's
upbringing and I think we just have a
lot in common
[Music]